LET’S GET RIGHT TO MY OPENING
STATEMENT.
SO HERE WE ARE ON MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND 2020.
THE QUINT ESSENTIAL HOLIDAY WITH
BEACH FUN AND BACKYARD
BARBEQUES.
THE DAY ITSELF RECOGNIZES THE
HEROES WHO GAVE THEIR LIVES SO
WE CAN LIVE FREE AND DO THESE
VERY THINGS.
WEEP DISPLAY THE AMERICAN FLAG
AND VISIT CEMETERIES AND
THANKING GOD THAT THERE WERE
HEROES WILLING TO DIE FOR THE
REST OF US.
BUT THIS HALLIDAY IS DIFFERENT.
AMERICA HAS BROUGHT TO HER KNEES
BY AN INVISIBLE ENEMY.
WE BUCKLED AND BOWED TO UNKNOWN
SCIENCE AND TO MODELS THAT WERE
MORE WRONG THAN RIGHT.
I’M NOT CRITICIZING ANYONE.
THEY WERE DOING THEIR BEST TO
PROTECT US.
BUT AUTHORITARIAN GOVERNORS AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS LOOKING TO FLEX
THEIR PATHETIC MUSCLES TO KEEP
US ON LOCKDOWN, ANOTHER STORY.
NEW YORK CITY AND L.A. ARE STILL
ON LOCKDOWN.
DEMOCRATIC MAYOR GARCETTI SAYS
LA WILL NOT FULLY OPEN UNTIL
THERE IS A VACCINE AND SCHOOLS
PROBABLY WILL NOT RE-OPEN UNTIL
KIDS CAN GET TESTED WEEKLY.
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM IN LINE
WITH HIM.
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO NEVER
FIGURED OUT SENIORS NEEDED TO BE
ISOLATED AND PROTECTED.
HE DID NOTHING WHEN PEOPLE
BEGGED THAT COVID PATIENTS NOT
BE PUT INTO NURSING FACILITIES
WHERE 5,800 SENIORS DIED.
GOVERNOR DEAND SOMETIMES
CRITICIZED MERCILESSLY FOR NOT
DOING ENOUGH EARLY ON LOST 1,000
SENIORS.
BUT HE KNEW TO PROTECT AND
ISOLATE THE SENIORS.
ALL THE WHILE GOVERNOR KE -- ALL
GOVERNOR CUOMO PONTIFICATED
ABOUT VENTILATORS.
AND THE MERCY SHIP HE DIDN’T
NEED.
AND THE AFTERITS CENTER RETURNED
BACK TO A CENTER.
LAST ONE DAY THREE CHURCHES WERE
HIT WITH FINES FOR HOLDING
SERVICES IN CHICAGO, WHILE
LIQUOR STORES, MARIJUANA
DISPENSARIES AND HOME DEPOT ARE
WIDE OPEN BECAUSE THEY ARE
CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL BUSINESSES.
AMERICANS WANT OUT OF THE
CHAINS THAT LOCK US IN OUR
HOMES.
THE VIRTUAL HOUSE ARREST ON US.
IT WON’T LET US ATTEND CHURCH
AND SEEMS TO PUNISH THOSE OF
WORK FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
FUTURES.
’.
DOCTORS RAISE ALARM ABOUT THE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF CONTINUED MASS
CAT OUGHT INCIDENT FROM THE
SHUTDOWN.
>> FOR SOME THERE WILL BE NO
BUSINESS TO REBUILT.
FOR OTHERS THERE WILL BE NO
COMING BACK FROM THE DEPTHS OF
DEPRESSION, ALCOHOL OR DRUG
ABUSE.
CANCELED ELECTIVE SURGERIES
PROLONGED EMOTIONAL PAIN AND
STRESS AND DEPRESSION.
THERE ARE 5 TO 10,000 DEATHS
OCCURRING FROM SUICIDE,
DEPRESSION, DRUG ADDICTION, LOSS
OF HOPE, BATTERED WOMEN LOCKED
AT HOME WITH THEIR ABUSERS,
ABUSED CHILDREN NOT BEING
IDENTIFIED OR PROTECTED BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT GO TO SCHOOL.
NOW EVEN THE FRONT COVER OF THE
NEW YORK POST READ, IT NEEDS TO
END NOW.
THE BIG APPLE IS DYING.
ITS STREETS ARE EMPTY.
TENS OF THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN
PLUNGED INTO POVERTY.
OUR LEADERS HAVE NO PLANS.
NO ANSWERS.
NEW YORKERS ALREADY LEARNED TO
SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
WE ARE PAST THE DANGER ZONE AND
AMERICANS KNOW IT.
THEY FEEL IT.
IN SOME STATES THEY PLAN TO COME
OUT AND PROTEST.
THE TOTALITARIAN ORDERS OF
POLITICIANS IN ILLINOIS,
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK.
THE QUESTIONS SO MANY AMERICANS
ASK, WAS IT NECESSARY FOR
GOVERNMENT TO SHUT DOWN IN THE
FIRST PLACE?
THAT QUESTION DOESN’T NEED TO BE
ANSWERED NOW.
WHAT’S DONE IS DONE.
BUT THE QUESTION THAT DOES NEED
TO BE ANSWERED NOW IS WHERE ANY
PART OF AMERICA IS SHUT DOWN.
WE NO LONGER NEED IT.
WE KNOW THE DANGER.
WE KNOW WHAT TO DO.
THE ELDERLY CAN ISOLATE.
WE GOT THIS.
THERE IS NO LONGER JUSTIFY CASE
FOR THIS D THERE IS NO LONGER
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS LOCKDOWN.
WHAT ARE WE WAITING FOR?
DON’T TELL ME A VACCINE.
WE DON’T KNOW WHEN AND HOW THAT
WILL HAPPEN.
THE LEFT SEIZES ON A NANNY
STATE, AN AUTHORITARIAN APPROACH
TO KEEP YOU SCARED, HOME AND
DOWN.
THAT INCLUDES HIDING JOE BIDEN
IN THE BASEMENT AS THEY
GLEEFULLY MOVE TOWARD THEIR
SIREN SONG OF SOCIALISM.
THE RIGHT WANT YOU TO CHOOSE
YOUR DESTINY, PATH AND FUTURE.
WE DON’T WANT TO BE TOLD HOW
MUCH WE NEED TO LIVE ON OR HOW
TO LIVE.
WE ARE A CAPITALIST SOCIETY.
WE KNOW THE DANGERS AND WE KNOW
HOW TO LIVE.
WE WON’T ALLOW THE LEFT TO
INFRINGE ON OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS, OUR FREEDOM OF SPEECH,
THE RIGHT TO EXERCISE OUR
RELIGION AND YOU CIVIL LIBERTIES
TO PEACEFULLY ADDRESS THE WRONGS
OF GOVERNMENT.
IN THE WORDS OF RONALD REAGAN,
THE GOVERNMENT’S FIRST DUTY IS
TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE.
NOT RUN THEIR LIVES.
SO ON THIS MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND
AS WE RECOGNIZE, RESPECT AND
HONOR THOSE WHO DIED DEFENDING
THESE VERY RIGHTS, IT’S
IMPORTANT THAT WE REAFFIRM OUR
FAITH IN THIS NATION, THAT IT IS
INDEED THE HOME OF THE FREE
BECAUSE OF THE BRAVE.
SO AS WE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE AMERICAN FLAG WE RECOGNIZE
TWO THINGS.
THE FLAG DOES NOT FLY BECAUSE
THE WIND MOVES IT, IT FLY WITH
THE LAST BREATH OF EACH SOLDIER
WHO DIED PROTECTING IT, WRITTEN
BY UNKNOWN.
TWO, WE ARE ONE NATION UNDER
GOD, INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.